what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
story lines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on uh later on in this
channel okay so as promised uh we are
going to cover the death of X event the
death of Cyclops now to provide a little
bit of context here to really do a
little bit of explanation we need to
talk about the teren Miss in terms of
what was going on and what what led up
to this current moment because one of
the big issues that I have with this
story was that writers Jeff lir and
Charles Soul didn't really provide any
explanation to this it was just the
teren misser on earth now this is
largely due to the very nature of all
new all different Marvel in the sense
that uh it really just kind of picks up
from before Secret Wars and it basically
nullifies the purpose of Secret Wars but
the idea here was that it it really just
kind of continued the ongoing themes and
so it requires us to really know what
was going on so historically speaking in
the realm of Marvel Comics uh the ter
and M are literally just gases that's
really all they are but they exist for
the purpose of allowing Inhumans to be
exposed to the myth and then taking on
their true form the problem with this is
that when a inhuman under go pyogenesis
it's a permanent genetic modification
meaning they can never go back to the
way they were before they're stuck that
way uh until the day they die you know
for the rest of their life now the teren
process or terog Genesis had been
tightly controlled by the inhuman royal
family which is to say black bold and
Medusa only those who were part of the
inhuman Royal City or who were in The in
human world city were allowed to undergo
terog Genesis and then they were very
closely monitored after which whatever
form they took on would establish what
role they played within the inhuman
Royal Family itself or the inhuman
community of aan the problem with all of
this stuff was that during Jonathan
Hickman's story Infinity which was part
of his run on Avengers and New Avengers
we had the villain Thanos show up on
Earth looking for his son F this led him
to a conflict with the Inhumans and in
the battle blackbolt of the Inhumans had
basically detonated the teren bomb and
what that did is it allowed the Mist to
spread all throughout the planet Earth
now this led into Charles souls or I
guess Charles Soul's story of inhumanity
or I guess it was inhuman and it also
led into inhumanity those are two
separate uh separate things but Charles
Soul's run basically told us that where
we originally thought it was just
blackbolt and the Inhumans in a tillin
there had actually been inhuman
communities all over the world that no
one ever knew about and had been
operating in secrecy for thousands of
years and so this really just allowed uh
Charles soul to bolster the ranks of the
Inhumans but it allowed him to introduce
what are called new Inhumans which were
the newer Inhumans that you heard about
that you had seen in Marvel Comics
recently with like NAA NAA I think is
how you pronounce it and so on and so
forth and so what death of X does is it
basically continues this trend of the
teren miss moving across the planet
Earth now after the teren bomb had been
detonated and after uh blackbolt had
basically been removed from his position
as king and Medusa taking his place as
Queen um you know after it got to the
point where all these Inhumans are being
woken up we saw different stories with
characters like lash and so on and so
forth but we had Crystal of the Inhumans
who is basically leading this sort of
field team that was designed for the
purpose of going around and finding uh
Inhumans who had just newly developed
with their powers and then basically
bringing them into the fold of the
official inhuman group the official
inhuman family as it was led by Medusa
now with regards to the main death of X
story again because of the fact that
this uh just kind of continues from
before Secret Wars there are a couple
gaps that are left here there are some
questions that are available here that
Marvel just doesn't answer but with
regards to this the answers that they do
give us are really just kind of like
basic nonsensical answers to be honest
like there's really no substance to them
so initially picking up with uh with
cyclop and Emma Frost this also comes
out of the X-Men run where Cyclops had
basically just like become the new
Magneto that's the easiest way to
describe him he'd become more fanatical
he'd become more dangerous that was the
purpose behind Brian Michael Bendis
introducing all new X-Men is it was
Beast going to the past and grabbing the
old X-Men bringing them to the present
day and showing Cyclops who he used to
be versus who he is now the problem with
this is that it didn't change cyclops's
mind he still believed himself to be
this kind of Messiah of mutant kind then
he was going to lead them to what he
considered to be greatness which was
basically a parallel to magnet idea that
mutants are going to take over the world
and so with this story we initially open
up with the mutants themselves with
cyclops's X-Men answering a distress
call from feir Island now what Jeff
lamir and what Charles Soul do is they
actually take the concept of the
Inhumans communicating with one another
and talking and they run it parallel
with the X-Men themselves so while
Cyclops and his team are investigating
this emergency we also have Crystal
leading her field team of Inhumans who
are heading towards Japan basically uh
where we're going to basically learn
that the the ter and Mist are making
their way there and so it's really just
kind of like all roads lead to Rome at
least that really seems to be what's
happening here and so with Cyclops and
his team arriving at New Island they
find this massive research facility now
this is something that had been that way
for a long time New Island had been a
huge research facility um and the most
notable person to to run alongside this
was more a MCT tager but there had also
been people who had who had you know
taken their leave here and there and had
worked and so on but when they get there
they basically find that all the mutant
researchers are dead all those
individuals who are mutants are are are
bleeding they they're suffering from
some extremely advanced version of of
small pox and it all just really seems
to be killing them and so picking up
with uh the Inhumans again picking up
with Crystal's team we again find them
basically traveling to where all these
Inhumans are are going into their cocoon
phase when they first are exposed to the
terrien mist and they're all beginning
to uh to emerge but in the middle of
this uh Hydra has basically shown up for
the purpose of capturing these cocoons
now uh we're not really given a reason
why Hydra is here but Hydra being what
it is Jeff lir and Charles Soul
basically say you guys know why they're
here you know of course their goal is to
basically capture these inhuman cocoons
and then indoctrinate the Inhumans into
the Hydra belief system and allow Hydra
to use them for their own purposes and
so while you have um you know Crystal
and her team fing off against Hydra
switching back to Cyclops and everybody
we also have all these different
multiple versions of Jamie madrock that
are all dead now Jimmy madro has long
since been retired here and this is
something that didn't really make any
sense and this is something that that
really kind of stood out to me and the
reason why is this Jimmy madro had
basically taken over the role as head of
xfactor and he had moved it away away
from being like a uh a government
sanctioned superhero team to being like
an investigative team not unlike uh
Jessica Jones Alias investigations
xfactor was a detective group more or
less and it worked for the stories we
were getting at the time I mean it
wasn't a standout publication but
xfactor never really was one of the
greatest standout Publications after the
Lis Simonson and Walt Simonson run when
they left the title and the original
X-Men went back to the main X-Men team
in the 1980s I think it was but uh but
the idea here is that uh Jamie madro had
long since retired and after he left he
had married Lila Miller um who is a
mutant that has the ability that's
basically immune from reality warping
but she also has the ability to to
resurrect the dead and to heal anyone
now her resurrecting the Dead uh has a
caveat that it you know she can only
resurrect those who have died within
moments you know so she would literally
have to have been right at Jimmy mad's
side when he died in order to make sure
that he came back from the dead but her
being able to heal him in this instance
he's basically he's surviving or at
least it seems like he's surviving with
a couple moments left in his life and uh
you know if Lela Miller had been around
or if he had even called his wife you
know she would have been able to
basically heal him restore him back to
normal but this didn't happen and so
it's really just kind of Charles soul
and Jeff lamir turning a blind eye to
the question of what happened with AA
Miller why isn't she healing her husband
where is she at it's really them just
kind of ignoring that whole thing
because in truth it would have created a
huge plot hole and the story probably
wouldn't have existed if Lila Miller
were were you know here right now but
the fact remains that once they get into
the facility and they begin poking
around we also have uh Cyclops becoming
ill Cyclops starts coughing and getting
sick now this would be a huge point for
the story uh later on but again jumping
back to the Inhumans we of course have
uh you know these new Inhumans going
against Hydra facing off against these
Hydra forces there's really not a whole
lot to see here but there is one inhuman
that that reemerged named dauki I think
it is and this is really just a guy that
has the power to emit these Rays these
forms of energy that essentially put
people to sleep and that's exactly what
he does you know he basically uses his
powers on Hydra and uh these hydra
agents end up passing out and collapsing
and as a result he's basically inducted
into the field team uh by Crystal just
because of the fact that his powers seem
to be so impressive and so from here we
have these two situations of the
Inhumans and the mutants being
paralleled against one another in the
sense that Crystal's talking to dauki
and she says hey look you know welcome
to the Inhumans you know you're part of
our group we watch out for our own we
always make sure our own are safe now
this is designed again to really mirror
cyclops's reaction in the sense that
where Crystal inducting dauki into the
Inhumans is a celebratory thing Cyclops
is saying like the this this teren mist
is killing us you know and it's my job
to make sure our mutants are protected
and so in effect he's basically going to
wage a war against the Inhumans uh due
to the fact that he looks at the
Inhumans themselves as a threat against
mutant kind now from this point we
basically jump to the the Newan you know
the the city of Newan with Medusa
herself now this is a meeting between
Medusa and storm this is actually pretty
important just because of the fact that
it shows us that not everybody's taking
cyclops's stance not everybody takes a
stance with Cyclops saying well the
Inhumans are are a threat now because
the teren Miss are killing us not only
that there's no answer really no
definitive answer given to us as to why
the teren Mr are killing the mutants
because keep in mind mutants have been
exposed to terrin myth multiple times
over the course of model's publication
history it's happened so many times
historically speaking I mean there's
been times where Magneto was exposed to
the Terin Mist there is this there's the
instance uh son of M after the house of
event where so many mutants lost their
powers that Quicksilver got the genius
idea to expose mutants to the teren miss
it jumpstarted their powers and it made
them too extreme for a lot of mutants to
handle but it didn't kill him you know
it didn't cause it didn't cause like
impo what's being called right now and
so this raises just as many questions of
well what happened like why are the M
suddenly different now and storm asked
this question and even Medusa asked this
question the only answer that's given
here is well the atmosphere somehow
change or they interact with the
atmosphere we don't really know this is
really just kind of Marvel saying
there's no answer to this we're just
doing this for the sake of the story
it's a little disappointing uh but you
know it doesn't change the fact that
this is where things are right now that
for whatever reason beyond the realm of
explanation that the terent myths have
somehow adjusted they've changed and the
result is that they're now killing
mutants as opposed to simply just
turning Inhumans or turning yeah I guess
allowing Inhumans to manifest themselves
now with storm basically leaving one of
the things that she says here is that
for her she wasn't sure whether or not
this was intentional whether or not it
was intentional of the Inhumans to
launch an attack against the X-Men now a
lot of you guys who've been reading the
reviews of death of X have probably
heard that phrase that the X-Men were
acting out of character that's what this
is referencing there's no reason
whatsoever for storm to believe that the
Inhumans are intentionally trying to
kill them especially considering the
fact that the Inhumans and the mutants
have worked together on a multitude of
occasions most notable instance of the
two groups working together was when the
son of Cyclops and meline prior Nathan
Nathan Summers was kidnapped by the
villain apocalypse uh when apocalypse
had attacked aellen and taken some of
the some of its citizenry as His Four
Horsemen Cyclops alongside blackbolt and
a multitude of Inhumans and X-Men fought
together against apocalypse they all
pretty much
lost but they fought against apocalypse
and they they held their own as long as
they could there's been a slew of
instances where the Inhumans and the
X-Men have worked together and so it
just kind of it seems to come out of
left field that suddenly storm doesn't
trust Medusa right now and suddenly
storm believes that Medusa is working
against them but again like I said this
is really just a lot of the characters
acting out of character this is one of
the things that doesn't really seem to
make a whole lot of sense but as storm
begins to take her leave we suddenly
have uh you know Emma Frost alongside
the Stepford cako allowing cyclops's
mind to be broadcast to the world as a
whole now to Sidetrack here for a second
the Stepford cako are a group that we've
never really talked about before but
they come out of Grant Morrison's new
X-Men and uh at least I believe it's
Grant Morrison's new X-Men it may be
Chuck Austin's time when he took over
the series but the idea here anyway is
that they came out of the new X-Men line
of stories and the the concept is
they're basically clones of Emma Frost
but they're not on the same level
individually Instead The Stepford kuss
had the ability to basically create a
hive mind of sorts now there were
originally four of them uh but one of
them died during Quinton choir's
Uprising at the Xavier Institute which
is actually a pretty cool story but it
really it was designed to show the
consequence of his you know recklessness
and the fact that he was uh he was
trying not to be a villain but being a
Villain at the same time uh but the the
idea here is that the seph cako is
working alongside emmafrost effectively
have the power of cerebro they're is a
they're capable as capable as cerebro
when Charles Xavier is using it by
broadcasting the the speech and the
manorisms and the thoughts of Cyclops
all across the world now the crazy thing
about this is Cyclops immediately takes
a stance the Inhumans are killing
mutants that's basically what his
message is his message is the Inhumans
during the events of infinity had
basically set off the teren bomb they
had spread you know this this terog
Genesis uh all across the planet and the
idea here is that their actions are
effectively to the death of mutants all
over the place not only that he also
begins to delve into the realm of
speculation and say well you know it may
also be fatal to humans now there's no
reason for Cyclops to believe this but
he's saying this for the simple purpose
of making his case and he's saying this
for the purpose of saying hey look like
you know we we need to get rid of the
Inhumans you know the Inhumans are the
threat now like we need to go to war
with the Inhumans so what if he he just
spouts a little bit of nonsense here and
there if he throws out some propaganda I
mean I'm not saying it saying it's okay
I'm saying from the perspective of the
story that's that's cyclops's stance
well so what if I'm lying a little bit
you know in the end still achieves the
goal of going to war with the Inhumans
and basically bringing the Inhumans down
and bringing the Earth back unto
ourselves now the funny thing about this
though is that in the middle of all this
we also have the X-Men themselves we
have Ilana Rasputin magic who again has
the ability to create dimensional
barriers and so on and so forth you know
they're all addressing Emma Frost and
they all say look we want to know what's
going on we want to know what the play
is because this was done without their
knowledge they didn't know that Cyclops
is going to broadcast to the world and
effectively wage war on the Inhumans
making them a target for all of humanity
to turn their sights on as opposed to
looking at mutants and so when they
initially ask questions imma Frost says
no not now we're busy now this is going
to be a really really really important
thing when we get to the end of the
story but from this point going forward
it's really all just Panic it's all just
pandemonium now the and humans are
actually doing the right thing here you
know because of what's going on because
the myths are proving deadly to mutants
the first thought of the Inhumans is
okay well then let's get the myths away
from the major cities you know I mean
let's let's get them away because keep
in mind the Inhumans can't simply
control the M under normal circumstances
it's not like they can just grab the ter
and Miss put put them back in a bottle I
mean the Genie's out of the bottle now I
mean there's nothing they can do all
they can do is try to move the teren
Mist but it's it's far too massive of a
cloud to confine into One Singular space
all over again there's really nothing
they can do and so what ends up
happening here is uh is Crystal along
with another inhuman they work together
in an effort to try to move this Cloud
now of course crystal is a character
that has the ability to control the
elements she's not on par with storm but
she does have the ability to control the
elements the issue with this is that
even between Crystal and this other
inhuman they're they're really not
capable of doing this you know is doing
the best she can but they're not able to
push it back on their own and so in the
end they're actually joined by storm and
storm allows you know I guess brings her
abilities to the table and the three of
them are successfully able to push this
massive cloud away from a populated city
which in turn basically shows that
they're trying to work alongside the
mutants and they're trying to make sure
that that things are coming out uh
successfully with one another now from
here we basically pick up with the
arrival of Colossus now the arrival of
Colossus is actually pretty cool just
because of the fact that he's a well
established character in The X-Men and
so one of the things that that you guys
will notice in a lot of the X-Men
Publications when it comes to certain
writers that they will pay special
attention to the legacy of of
individuals for example with with
Colossus he would you know he first
popped up on the scene with giant size
X-Men issue number one he's been around
as in in Marvel comic since 1975 he's
one of the longest running X-Men aside
from the original five of Cyclops Angel
Warren Worthington uh Beast Iceman and
Jean Gray he's one of the original ones
you know one of the original guys I
guess he's he's the next generation of
the of the new original guys if that
makes any sense but the fact remains
here that he holds a lot of Cloud this
is especially important because of the
fact that when the Legacy virus showed
up when it was created you know and it
began killing mutants s all over the
place he sacrificed his life to develop
a cure now of course he did come back
during Jos Sweden's run of astonishing
X-Men but the idea is that Colossus has
routinely put his life on the line to
preserve the lives of others and so with
his arrival it's really a a scenario
where he's not to be ignored and so he
alongside uh you know magic Ilana
Rasputin say we want to know what's
going on we want to know what's
happening here right now and so the
result is that we essentially have uh
you know Cyclops saying okay you know
what we're doing is we're basically
Gathering the most powerful mutants that
we can find the most capable mutants
that we can find in order to save what
mutants are left and then we're all
going to go to war with the Inhumans
that's really just his stance here
that's really his position saying we're
we're all just going to destroy him and
so you know from this point going
forward it's really the you know I guess
crystals and human team trying to uh
manage the chaos and the reason for this
is because you know with a cloud that
was heading towards Madrid there were a
lot of people who were panicking there
were a lot of people who were freaking
out they believe their death was
imminent because of what Cyclops said
and so what Crystal does is she has
dauki uses powers to basically put
everybody to sleep to put everybody to
rest now keep in mind you know dauki
doesn't have total control over his
abilities yet and the result is that
when he uses them everyone's affected
except for the Inhumans meaning that the
X-Men of Storm's team are all put to
sleep and so switching over to Emma
Frost we essentially have her uh
communicating with Magneto and she
essentially says look we need you here
now Emma Frost saying this is not not to
be taken lightly it's not something
small it's not an unreasonable thing
this is a big deal because you know
Magneto is a guy that's routinely gone
against the X-Men but but if Magneto is
good at anything it's being a leader
he's extremely good at leading groups of
people it doesn't necessarily mean he
leads them to Victory consistently but
it does mean that when it comes down to
it he's definitely a guy that you want
to have in your corner and so you know
following this uh you know the I guess
isuki using his powers in in Madrid the
most logical scenario happens in the
sense that the X-Men begin to come too
and when they do they basically look at
the humans as though they were working
against them you know crystal says Hey
we've got to go get everybody together
we've got to wake the mutants up we've
got to make sure everything's sorted out
but you know storm enter team have more
or less turned against them and saying
you know we thought you were on our side
but when we came here to help you used
your powers on us you know in a way that
was not beneficial you know you
effectively put us to sleep because you
considered us just as panicky and just
as dangerous as everybody else now again
this is pretty out of character for
these guys I mean it's pretty out of
character for storm to react in such a
panicky way but it doesn't change the
fact that this is the idea that she's
going for this is the this is where her
character is right now with regards to
the confines of the story and so from
here we actually switch to Yorkshire
England and we pick up with the uh with
the sephar Coco and they're going to
grab a guy named Alchemy now we'll talk
about him a little more here in a second
but Alchemy is actually a pretty capable
mutant he's pretty powerful in terms of
the kind of things that he can do he's
not reality working powerful but he is
pretty capable and so following this we
basically learn that Emma Frost bringing
together I guess you know bringing and
Magneto bringing him into the fold
alongside Colossus and and you know wolf
Spain and several others was not
designed to inherently wage war against
the Inhumans it was designed to serve a
purpose of distraction and the reason
why is because Magneto shows up and
begins you know to bombard them begins
to encase them and the X-Men and the
Inhumans are both on the Counterattack
trying to uh trying to stay alive really
as best they can but also trying to
figure out what it is that Magneto is
doing and so switching over to Cyclops
alongside Emma Frost in the arrival of
alchemy this is when we get a chance to
talk about his character so Alchemy is a
guy when he first showed up he had the
ability to turn objects into gold he
really had like the mightest touch well
the reason why they called him Alchemy
is of course Alchemy was the study or at
least at one one fastet of alchemy was a
study of you know turning objects into
gold creating gold so on and so forth
But as time progressed his powers
evolved to the point where at least he
he gained enough control over his powers
that he could essentially manipulate the
chemical structure of things and so he
could turn gases into other things he
could turn water into something else he
could turn you know a physical object
into something else he can manipulate
the chemical structure of matter in
order to to transmogrify basically now
this does not mean he can warp reality
this simply just means that he can take
a gas turn it into a liquid turn a
liquid into a gas rearrange the
molecular structure of anything that's
in a liquid gas or uh or solid state and
then you know allow it to go from there
and so what we learn is that the basis
behind him being here is to literally
assault the teren cloud to basically
change the teren cloud now of course
once this happens you know once the the
X-Men of I'm sorry once a Medusa enter
team basically realize what's going on
that um you know Cyclops is going to try
to eliminate the teren cloud this leads
to a conflict between the two and the
reason why is because Medusa recognizes
the danger of the Teran Cloud right like
she realizes that it's going to that
that it is killing X-Men but in her mind
it's also bringing her people out of
seclusion it's allowing her to bolster
the ranks of Inhumans and in her mind if
it increases the number of Inhumans and
that's the rightful role they're
supposed to play is that's that's her
role as Queen is to ensure that those
people who are Inhumans learn about
their gifts and are brought into the
inhuman fold and so in her mind the
Cyclops is basically blocking her way is
essentially stripping her of her power
and uh and and basically denying those
people who are Inhumans their Birthright
and so because of this you know of
course she she attacks a Sunfire who's
there for the purpose of allowing you
know Alchemy to get up to the cloud and
you know change it and so on but while
the Inhumans are distracted at the very
least or at least while it seems like
they're delayed uh under the belief that
they sto Cyclops from having this Cloud
altered uh we find out that that Sunfire
was successful in doing this that
Sunfire was successful in taking Alchemy
to this cloud and allowing him to alter
the molecular structure of this Cloud so
that it's no longer teren you know teren
Mist in its normal form and it's no
longer poisonous to mutants the result
of this is that this just kind of
creates an allout conflict between the
two groups simply because of the fact
that in the eyes of Medusa this is some
that's crossing the line this is
something that that is beyond
unreasonable now the other half of this
is that blackbolt had kind of been
holding back this whole time because as
we know blackbolt is really more of a
Hands-On guy and so the notion here was
to was for Medusa to basically say let's
use diplomacy to solve this problem but
if we cannot use diplomacy then
blackbolt you step in and that's exactly
what happens you know because of the
fact that this this Cloud's been
destroyed because of the fact that no
more in humans you know will really be
waking up or at least it doesn't seem
that way uh in response blackbolt uses
his voice shouts at at Cyclops and
completely destroys his body and so
picking up like like literally we just
get like the death of Cyclops and then
one week later there's no middle ground
here like we literally just jump to a
week later but picking up we basically
have storm offering the eulogy at the uh
at the burial of Cyclops you know at his
funeral and then we also have Emma Frost
meeting with uh with Havoc now her
meeting with Havoc is basically the
Revelation to everything that's been
going on and what we learn here is that
almost immediately after Cyclops had
been exposed to the teren Mist he had
succumbed to this effect uh he had or at
least it seemed like he had essentially
died and so the result was that
everything that had taken place in the
story from the time that really after
Cyclops had left the facility at Mir
Island all the way up to his death at
the hands of blackbolt was all fake that
was all an illusion that had been
created by Emma Frost and the reason she
did this was because she wanted Cyclops
to be a martyr she wanted Cyclops to be
an ideology mutants could rally behind
now the core basis behind why she did
this is something that we'll probably
find out in the Inhumans versus X-Men
story but for right now this is really
just the gist of it it's really the fact
that yes Cyclops died but he didn't die
because he was killed by blackbolt he
died because he was exposed to the teren
m and and the result was that emmafrost
had basically used her powers to trick
the world into believing that Inhumans
were inherently evil that Inhumans were
the reason why mutants were being killed
that in humans were intentionally and
systematically targeting mutants not
only that she had basically instigated
the scenar SC Ario for why the Inhumans
and the X-Men are going to go to war
against each other in the first place
anyway but with that being said we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end if you guys are new here to
comment explain be sure to hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video drop a like
and uh leave a comment down below let me
know what you guys think about um about
uh this story Death of
X God that brain fart I have ADD so bad
it's not even funny but yeah leave a
comment let me know what you guys
thought about death of X and uh yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
peace